I can't worry about like
okay let's go ahead and start again so I
want to give a one slide
progress report of lower bounds that
have been proved in this vein from album
design over the last several years so as
I spoke about just a moment ago some of
the state of the art for a cc lower
balances that quasi MP doesn't have a DC
of threshold circuits of polynomial size
and just to say a bit about how this
it's Sat algorithm works I won't really
be able to talk about the satyr runs
here you can look at the the bootcamp
slides there they're still relevant for
the satire of them here so it uses a new
depth to representation of these ADC of
thresholds so use some how represent it
as a symmetric boolean function of
symmetric boolean functions and some
fast rectangular matrix multiplication
to evaluate this thing quickly and sort
of beat exhaustive search so improving
these lower bounds to say multiple
layers of linear threshold gates where
say objects or this kind of feeding into
objects of this kind and then outputting
answers is the open frontier so the
state of the art is that there are
functions in e to the NP so this is like
time 2 to the order n with an NP Oracle
very powerful doesn't have a cc of
threshold of threshold circuits of
sub-quadratic size so into the 1.9 gates
okay this is you know pretty pretty weak
of a lower bound like somehow like you
know what we know is actually
essentially exponential whenever we just
have one layer of threshold so we add
one more the techniques we have kind of
fall apart so but this lower bounds that
are known they they use probabilistic
Pownall's for for the threshold function
that are optimal so for a threshold on
on in a boolean variables you can get a
so-called probabilistic representation
probabilistic palm
of degree a about square root of n times
some poly log factors and so this is
sort of where the sub-quadratic size
lower bound comes from and it's open for
example whether quasi and P has
threshold threshold circuits of so
quadratic survive I feel like questions
of this former something that we could
possibly attack by studying the
connections between albums and lower
bounds better and just sort of working
with what we already know so some work
by China and Pakistan Tina showed a
better size depth trade-off lower bound
for NX versus ACC essentially the lower
bound they can show is so well so like
there's a size select the number of
gates and versus the depth so here's the
depth of three the size deplore a trade
off flow around they have is so good
that if you improved it asymptotically
you would actually prove NX is not an NC
1 billion formula [ __ ] sized a
presumably even bigger class so they
have a pretty strong size depth
trade-offs that are known now for these
things using kind of the known
transformations of ACC into interesting
representations sort of depth to
representations another Chen where we
winch in this is attention with Olivera
and santhanam showed average case lower
bounds so for n X so not only can you
prove sort of lower balance for ACC but
you can also show that there aren't
circuits that compute even slightly
greater than 50% fraction of him being
on post career
so this is another direction which
people who have been looking at and this
is a sentence carefully applies coding
theory techniques on top of the existing
framework which I'm going to describe it
a little bit of detail not the coding
Theory like techniques but the but the
frame whatever this framework thing
means and something I alluded to before
so impede doesn't have fixed polynomial
size so I put a hundred there you can
put any fixed constant size depth to
neural networks with sine activation
function nor with Ray Lewis evasion
functions so this roughly translates to
a linear combination over the reals of
linear threshold functions are linear
combination of the reals of something
called Ray Lu which I will hopefully get
to defining at the heart of this is a
very old algorithmic technique from the
70s which just uses sorting and
searching so Horwitz and Sonny show that
say counting subsets some solutions on
and items can be done faster than
enumerate all possible subsets um so
some kind of meat in the middle type
thing you get square root of of to v8 so
that's kind of the algorithm at the
heart of this thing which is proving
lower bounds against NP which I think is
very interesting and I feel like like
we're these lower bounds are being
proved that it's some kind of distance
and maybe I mean like sorting and
searching somehow should not be so
powerful to proof new lower bounds in
this way is so what is really going on
and party is there's a much simpler
function which doesn't have these things
either and it's this is just sort of
what we can show given what we have
right now
right so in this hour I'm gonna be
describing these two years also so cause
EMP doesn't have a TC of thresholds of
poly size and these sort of fixed
polynomial lower bounds for NP because I
only have about 50 minutes now I won't
be able to give lots of details but I
hope that you at least see the moving
parts and sort of how they how they work
and perhaps the other bootcamp lectures
or I can give more talks about it later
so let's start with lower bounds for say
NX from quasi NP and MP from non-trivial
gap set algorithms so this is what I was
talking about in the previous hour like
these connections I want to say a bit
about how they work so first sort of how
the first lower bound was proved so you
take some typical circuit class like HEC
typical here just means it has nice
closure property say closed under ands
and ORS say
so the first theorem that was shown to
prove this lower bound was so we call it
theorem a some algorithm design implies
the word balancing so just to recall it
was a statement the form for all K if
this gap he said problem in the case
size can be solving to the end here I
divided by and the K divided by into 10
as I do last time then X doesn't have
poly size C circuits okay so that was
part one in the paper and part two who
was an algorithm part two said so you
tell me the depth of your htc circuit so
like here it's three you tell me the mod
in your circuit here it's six then I
will tell you an epsilon such that your
circuit set problem on to the and the
epsilon size is into the end - in the
epsilon time so on sub X potential size
I'm dividing by a sub exponential factor
this is covered in the boot camp of from
2015 that I gave so it uses a well-known
representation of ACC known for many
years and people long suspected it
should imply lower bounds
and this is just one way of actually
getting a handle on it and sort of
exploiting like this this weakness of
that seems to follow from this
representation okay so the thing I want
to note here is the inefficiency in the
way these two things line up so for one
I'm solving set
whereas I only need to solve the gap is
that problem okay but also the the
algorithm is solving things on some
exponential size and dividing by its
eventual factor whereas I only need
divided by super polynomial factor and
work for polynomial sizes and so this is
exactly the starting point of this most
recent work with Kody meri in which we
want to show that actually if you have
some set album with these kinds of
parameters that in fact you can improve
the NX to an honest equality polynomial
so the known for a long time there was
some kind of inefficiency in the
argument but it's still not sure you
know maybe the gap ACC Sat problem is
it's much easier to solve than this I
don't I don't know
so now I want to talk about theorem a I
won't talk about the algorithms here so
I want to talk about sort of how this
connection works because I I feel like
the this is a source where for more
improvement because it's sort of the the
part that we have been improving very
recently so again we want to get from
faster gaps at algorithms where you're
promised unsatisfiable or at least half
satisfiable we want to get in x4 bounds
okay so the idea is to show that if we
assume 1 in XPath small circuits okay
and you have this faster gap set
algorithm with these parameters then we
can get a contradiction so in particular
we will show that so if every problem
solvable in to the end time
non-deterministically can be solved in
little o of to the end time not a
turistic aliso all problems with to the
end link solutions verifiable on to the
end time you can compress the solution
lengths and verify the solution lengths
faster ok which contradicts the so
called non eternal sick time higher key
theorem as you strictly increase the
time you're taking to solve problems
roughly speaking there are strictly more
problems you can solve for me there's
more there's lots of formalizations of
this but that's that's the idea so we've
just wanted to show that like these two
kind of positive assumptions are just
way too good to be true in conjunction
so how does this work at a really high
level so we want to show any problem
solve 106 union time can be you're
implementing this little faster so take
any problem in this class here so given
an input X how do we compute such a
language on X well there's a very
standard way just by definition of
non-determinism we guess the witness of
order to the end links and we check that
the witness we guessed works in order to
the end time okay so the goal is to
speed up both of these steps the
guessing of the witness and the checking
of the witness so they run in little o
to the end time using these two
hypotheses okay speed up both parts 1
and 2 using the above assumptions and
when you think of it this way the the
kind of problem we want to solve cleanly
separates so like assumption 1 is in
some shinto like how they're being used
it's it's pretty clear so so we take any
problem again and on Thursday to noon
time so give it an input X we will
compute it under the instructions so in
the following way so part 1 says in
excess poly sized circuits we can in
fact conclude from this that there are
witnesses for every X that are in the
language there are witnesses of a little
low to the in lengths in fact polynomial
length and this follows from something
that I will describe detail call it easy
witness lemma that if in X is in P poly
then L has small witnesses there are
compressible witnesses you can use okay
so this so we're directly using
assumption we want to speed up the
guessing of the witness and then
assumption 2 is used to do the faster
checking okay so so given that we have
say some compressed version of a witness
we want to check that this compressed
version is indeed a witness and the idea
is that there these things are
probabilistic checkable proofs that
allow us to so take any MP problem in
fact in X problems and there will be
proof that we can randomly
a constant number of places and verify
the proof with with high confidence okay
so this step two is going to use a
highly structured PC ps4 NX that you
know things that so I used it in this
original paper and benzo song and viola
really optimized this thing to reduce
this check of the witness to a gap see
set our them so that your gap see set
algorithm is literally playing the role
of verifier like so it use you set up a
circuit with a PCP such that if this if
the witness you guess is right then sort
of all the constraints of the PCP are
satisfied and that will correspond to
the circuit being unsatisfiable and if
if like X is not a language then no
matter what circuit you guess no matter
what witness you have okay say at least
a half of the constraints are not going
to be satisfied and this will correspond
directly to at least half of the
assignments to the circuit will output
one so the circuit is literally checking
individual constraints of this BCP so
yes time to to the 2n so like you mean
if I put like four to the end here
everywhere you can get a contradiction
that way too
yeah I mean like I think I just said to
the end because it's like tonight it's
like you know the simplest exponential I
mean the base of the exponent doesn't
really matter here
you get two for two the end of both
sides yeah it'd be like four to the N is
in little over 40 which is also a
contradiction yeah yeah be the I mean
the yeah it won't yes maybe try to order
the animal labs and it still had to the
end the right for you know left well
then I mean that's even harder to speed
up right you speak you're trying to
speed up by a square root that's even
harder you need like you need like
checking that was that does square root
up to the end faster but like we don't
need that
so like you want to get like the
contradiction as quickly as possible so
you want to take like sort of the the
tightest kind of lower bound statement
you have so this is like more as tight
as it can get yeah you'd get like to the
N in strictly sub-exponential yeah all
this other stuff is that gonna be fine
yeah but but this is like it's like
totally overkill if your goal is to get
a contradiction and you already the
contradiction to get little o to you you
promise that the circuit is are there
unsatisfiable or at least half its
silencer satisfying so the point is a
PCP will enforce this kind of promise
for you either
yeah it's the same kind of gap I mean
there's complete so I'm talking about
perfect completeness and constant
soundness so but like so the point is
every assignment is like like I is
saying check the i th constraint right
and I output 0 if it's good so if it's
unsatisfiable all the constraints are
good but if it's not in the language and
I'm trying to fool you then half the
constraints will be bad sort of no
matter what I gave you to fool so that's
where the gap will come in
they witnesses local each yeah yeah I'm
not gonna talk about that but like the
point is there's superstructure PCBs you
can generate the constraints very very
efficiently any constraint you want and
then you got a probe like the witness
and with that we have like some let in
succinct representation for those
witnesses which I will talk about which
you can just sort of stick in like
copies of this thing which is yeah
that's true yeah but yeah I mean I don't
see a real advantage to that in on
technical level right yeah I mean the
PCBs are just really tight like they're
Paris
so so this I am I mean this is very
technical it's highly optimized so I'm
not sure how much more improvement could
be gotten from this step without some
like I don't told the different approach
so I'm going to talk about the easy
witness limit because this is the thing
that was recently improved to get the
better lower bounds so again our step is
like we want to decide whether input X's
in a language and we want to guess a
witness Y of order to ten links so so
we'll have this definition here about
like it's something that an in time to
the in problem might have or not so we
say a problem L has easy witnesses if
the following is true so there exists a
constant C so this thing of this is just
the degree of some polynomial for all
there are fires for this problem l so if
we have a witness which is you know some
power of two so that the verifier
accepts on that witness then this
witness can be compressed in the
following sense there exists a circuit D
sub X of only polynomial size and it has
a length of X plus the input so like the
log of the length of this thing so that
when I take the truth table of this
circuit so it has this many inputs so
the truth tables of link to to that I
think the truth table and plug it in
that is also a witness so it's four
once again a little deep
so it just means so this is just like
there's some D and it says for all
verifiers and for all X so for any input
X if there is some witness which is
let's say a power of two that works then
there is a circuit whose truth table is
also a witness but this but this circuit
is much much smaller than its truth
table with so the easy witness lemma of
impossible cabinets and vigorous and
says if n X is in P Polly okay so if we
have small circuits for solving n X
problems but this is just solving the
problem just telling me yes or no answer
for the every instance then all in X
problems have easy witnesses so there
are small circuits for the solutions to
NX problem so if you can solve the
problem in a compressed way then there
are solutions that can be compressed for
every yes instance of the problem and
for any verifier you want okay this is a
little technical govision that it needs
to be like a link to the power to but
this is very easy to enforce for any
particular verifier so the idea is that
if we are assuming in accident ppalli
then we can replace part one with a one
prime which is instead of guessing at to
the end length witness we just guessed
this circuit which is going to exist so
we want we take we we pick whatever
verifier we want here we're gonna pick a
PCB verifier okay oh the nice PCB and
then we'll guess a Paulo sized circuit
that's encoding a witness for X if there
is a witness then there is one which is
compressible in this way
that's what the easy witness lemma says
I will talk about this in the proof of
this we go so so then here's how the the
sketch of the proof goes so we are going
to compute L on some input X by guessing
this witness by using this easy witness
lemma and then we'll use our faster gap
see set album so we have some small
circuit encoding witness means we
basically have a random access to any
bit of the witness we want just by
plugging in you know say some integer I
and the input of this circuit D sub X
and it will tell us the bit of the
witness so we can set up some gap C set
our room which has copies of this
circuit D sub X in it and then check
whether all the constraints of the PCP
are satisfied by the assignment encoded
by D sub X all right so so how would we
improve that so this is what Cody and I
recently did so just to recall we said
if there is an Epsilon
so that gap CSAT them to the in the
epsilon size is in to the N minus in the
epsilon time then we get quasi Palio
time doesn't have high size C circuits
and moreover if we could get even faster
gaps at our runs on larger circuit sizes
we get lower bounds for NP and it was
observed among a couple of other things
by Rory tell that in fact you could have
any super polynomial time here and
doesn't have pi sighs I see serious this
by just taking some complete language
from this and doing a padding type
argument so how would we show this kind
of theorem so I'll just look at theorem
this theorem a plus plus so the thing
about MP so we want to show that given
that MP has really small circuits and we
have a faster gap so you said algorithm
we like to get a contradiction to some
non-deterministic primary key theorem so
in time into the D isn't in time below
of n the deep sum D so here's the idea
that we'd like to do so we'd like to say
if you give me some arbitrary problem
and in the D time we can somehow guess
some witness that's short and verify the
witness works in a quick amount of time
okay so it turns out that this nice PCP
thing is very parameterize abow and it
will still work if provided that you
know if we had like a way to encode
witnesses in some compressed way the
problem is that the easy witness lemma
of ikw really only works for for an
alternative exponential time like the
proof just sort of inherently requires
this and so this is what Cody and I were
able to prove some new kind of easy when
this lemma which is which works
with 4nq P and NP and other times in
between oh yeah in fact you get
something yeah you you get some
improvement in the exponent in fact yeah
but yeah that's no no no crazy see right
for example
yeah this kind of algorithm is not known
for a cc this is just this is just a
general statement it is known for other
things but but it's not known for a cc
so we don't know it's like fixed poorer
lower balance really please do with
something else and still like yeah yeah
so so the nqp version has like to to the
end of the epsilon here like instead of
epsilon in and you know you're assuming
quasi Polly has say polynomial size
instead yeah yeah yeah but I'm just
gonna talk about this one okay so maybe
a bit cleaner just talking about
polynomials instead of quasi-polynomial
so the new easy witness limo that we
proof is so here's like a more general
statement about of witness circuits so
in time T of n has ested in size witness
circuits if basically every problem in
time to the end with in all that's
verifiers and all this justices you can
find some s of inside circuit whose
truth table is a is a good witness about
a witness for that this is all easy
witness lemma was this one and the new
easy win assignment well here's a
special case of it is that if every
prominent MP has into the case sized
circuits then NP has into the order K
cube size witness circuits okay a
similar statement holds for a
quasi-polynomial time so there is some
little blow-up and the witness circuits
but the point is this in fact this will
hold for every NP problem including
problems which could have non-traumatic
running time into the ke - ke - ke - ke
- ke - ke keep like you know gigantic
running time so gigantic solutions they
can always be compressive some fixed
polynomial assuming the problems can be
solved and some fixed
the circus with the key log an input
source I'm just saying and yeah so this
would be so yeah these things well NP so
whatever it is like it's into the sea
right so these things would have C login
inputs and into the K cube sighs yeah
but see could be much much bigger but
intuitively this is why I like having a
gap set album that improves 1.9 the N is
useful because like the real the the
sort of ratio or wherever but doing that
compares something the circuit size and
the inputs this is like an exponential
yeah it's Peter the NP I guess we
claimed it or son right anybody see the
MP has in the case I circuits and NP has
whatever order may be ho tilde on the
case is much easier to show yeah so
general can you replace K with something
which is non constant and that you get
it to the point okay or is more
complicated so it's me so the general
case has like a dependence on like the
circuit size s of n the running time T
of N and so on so here if you have like
in timing of the pile log and then you
have in the log in size let's say in in
the log in size here then you have like
into the let's say log to the 3 in size
there so you basically compose the
function
yeah
so it's essentially like you have some
composition of this circuit sighs yeah
yeah I mean you sticking some
polynomials in there too but yeah so how
did we prove this kind of theorem so
we'd like to take the same approach as
we did with within X show something like
this so just at a really high level so
if we will you'll just start with like
end time into the K to the 4 and it just
goes 4 is larger than 3 okay so this to
solve L faster on input X the idea is
that we would we would get some circuit
there's some some fixed Paula no sighs
so in the K cube size with Katie the for
login input so it's encoding like it's
truth table and codes of witness for X
and this uses the easy witness lemma and
then the idea is you would check that
this does encode a witness
using your faster gaps album which works
for sort of things sub exponential in
the number of inputs you know which is
like K the for and and slightly faster
than into the cave the for time that's
like a really high level how the thing
would work yeah 30 minutes left and okay
see so so I wanna I want to describe ikw
is easy witness lemma and where we
depart from it because I think this is
an important component be essentially
because we were optimizing it may be
more optimization as possible well yeah
the way I want to phrase it as if in
time to the N is in size and the K for
some K so everything has in the case I
circuits then everything also has it in
the sea size witnessed circuits for some
C okay
and the strategy this is before is to
assume the negation and prove a
contradiction so we assume we have small
circuits and we assume this kind of
weird thing that like for all C there is
some problem to the end that doesn't
have in the C size with
circuits and the idea is to somehow like
I think the like the ingenuity in this
argument is figure out how to exploit
this this assumption to so the way i KW
do it they start with a problem that is
solvable in space in the K plus 1 but
it's not solvable and in the case eyes
even in FLE often so on every single
input length past a certain point
there's a problem solvable in the k plus
1 space that isn't doesn't happen in the
case size circus and this is done
essentially by a direct kind of
diagonalization okay but like you
because you can enumerate all the
possible circuits of size indicate and
the k plus 1 like you can have something
which on every single input length pass
some fixed point doesn't have it in the
case sized circuits that's what this IO
thing means so so it's like it's not not
even in fly off there's not even
implementing input links for which you
can get this simulation so they show how
assumptions 1 & 2 imply this chain of
inclusions which is a contradiction so
so let me say a bit about these
conclusions so this ma stands for Merlin
Arthur protocols it's like a
probabilistic version of MP and this IO
in time to the N means you're simulating
non-toxic time in fly often within bits
of advice essentially what's going on is
that with assumption 1 you can so if n
time to the N is in size in the K then
sort of you can say that space order n
is also in size order indicate okay and
this actually means that p space is in p
Polly okay and it's it's there's a carp
lipton type class result which shows
that if p space in ppalli then p space
is an MA the one way to prove it goes
through sort of interactive proofs the
fact that P space equals IP the idea is
that if P space in P Polly
there's a poli-sci circuit to encode the
prover strategy in an IP protocol you
could guess such a thing with Merlin
and then publicly verify it with Arthur
by running the the protocol okay so this
so this will let us say that say P
spaces enemy but in in particular space
in the K plus 1 is an MA and then
assumption 2 is used to do this very
partial kind of D randomization okay so
Merlin or Arthur is essentially MP but
with probabilistic verification and so
here we're getting sort of just non
determinism so we're doing some kind of
deterministic type of verification I
don't have time to describe it but the
slides I guess will be on the web but
assuming that end time today and doesn't
have in the C size witness circuits this
this gives you some way to get your
hands on a function without in the C
size circuits if I tell you within bits
of advice say a bad input for which
which has a say a certificate it has a
witness but all those witnesses have
high circuit complexity this is what it
means to not having to the seaside
circuits if I tell you a bad input which
doesn't have small circuits then I could
just guess a witness in order to the in
time and be sure that it doesn't have it
in the C size circuits so think of it as
a truth table okay and this is happening
in fleeing often so it's happening for
implementing inputs if assumption 2
holds so then we use like just a
standard translation of hardness into
pseudo randomness so given a truth table
access to a hard function we can
construct a pseudo-random generator
sort of a gift so if I have access to
some thing that doesn't have in the C
size circuits then I can get a sudra
Imjin arrogance size into the Omega C
you know if there's some constant there
okay so so I'm going to use like this
bad verifier which you know who all of
its uh good witnesses are actually of
highest or complexity to get my hands on
a heart function and then
run a serum generator from there so
that's that's sort of how this step goes
and then this step follows almost
immediately from step one so like if you
stick in in bits of advice you could
just hard who that in the circuit and if
it holds almost everywhere it holds iOS
as well sorry for that but yeah I
realized it like I don't have time to
see well my slides and to the square of
weakness circuits but I'm not into I'm
into the C squared circuits of the new
if it I'm not really sure what your
another permissive is explanation
because you're like guessing the entire
truth table yeah bigger circuit and that
eats proof table gives your witness but
you don't have a smaller circuit so what
are these things do you want to like
change into the login yeah so this is
okay so this is exactly like what we'd
like to scale this to NP that's not what
breaks so so yeah if you followed what
you know like say 80% of what I just
said then you will see let me see
so let me just go to the thing that
because the point is we would like to
take the same argument but it assume
like it only mps fix poly size circuits
for example and get it to work right so
so this is the new easy witness limo we
want to show actually maybe whatever
it's fine so so if MPs in the case eyes
circuits and MPs into the order K cube
size circuit so we want to derive a
contradiction from assuming that you
have the small circuits and you don't
have small witness circuits okay so the
way we do this is from a new lower bound
for Merlin our third protocol so we
can't actually go through this piece
base ma so on and so forth
mainly because just assuming NP is in
fixed poly size tells us nothing about
the circuit complexity of P space so we
don't get like P space equals MA so we
have to be more direct we have to
basically start from Ma and try to get a
contradiction with a lower bound a
really high level that this is this is
sort of how we we have to work and so to
do this we we prove a new lower bound
for a moment our third protocols so we
say for all constants K there is some
language in MA time into the K squared
with log and bits of advice so that for
all but finitely many input links in so
almost everywhere either the the problem
on n bit inputs has sir complexity at
least in of the K or the problem in the
K bit inputs has circumplex at least in
the K squared so for every input length
who get at least one of these two
guarantees if we had just some normal
almost everywhere lower bound then
essentially the argument I was telling
you about D randomization and whatever
would still go through but fortunate
this is what we can prove and luckily
it's enough to get the the contradiction
that we we want so our proof of the new
easy witness limit shows that if every
prominent MP is in the case sized
circuits but some problem doesn't have
order in the K cube size witnesses then
this above lower bound is contradicted
so so I'll just say a bit about that and
then get to the other topic I wanted to
say so we start with this problem from
our new circuit lower bound so assuming
some MP problem doesn't have any cake
you've size witnesses we can derive a
partial deer analyzation of this MA
protocol through language so in
particular we can show that for
implementing in so like for the in for
the inputs which this problem doesn't
have small witnesses there is some MP
with small advice algorithm so here I'm
going to encode the bad input that
computes this L correctly on all inputs
of LinkedIn and of length in the decay
so the trick is I have chosen my witness
size to be much larger than into the K
square I may indicate cubed and so so if
I get like a hard function that's that
hard then using so once I get my hands
on that function I can do analyze links
in the K inputs because they run in into
the K cubed sorry if it's this runs it
in the K squared and I can D randomized
length in inputs like with the same bad
input so so once I get my hands on a
hard-enough
function I can D randomize both input
links so assuming MP has in the case
size circuits using just applying this
we can derive for implementing in this
language on in input in bit inputs has
in the case I circuit and on in the K
bit input says it in the K squared sized
circuit okay and this directly
contradicts the lower bound that we got
unfortunately this is sort of all the
details I can give you and now I'm going
to switch to something totally different
so there you go in my in my last
okay but that but I didn't really leave
out like any of the main moving parts
that are going on so so now I want to
talk about lower bounds for MP against
some depth to classes so war grounds
want to talk about now our special cases
of a more generic a problem that I call
the our linear representation problem
and I think would be a great source of
lower bound questions to look at this
semester so you take some class of
simple functions see they could take
they take any boolean inputs but they
need not be boolean values they might
not output boolean values
so the general question is which
interesting functions can and cannot be
represented by short or linear
combinations of functions from C so
other words arbitrary linear
combinations of functions from the
simple class so so like I have some
function that takes bits and outputs
bits and I want to know can I get a
polynomial size or polynomial sparse
linear combination with like arbitrary
reals plugged in there where each thing
here is just some simple function so I
fixed some class of simple functions I
just want to what can be done with
linear combinations of this but yeah I'm
competing the thing exactly so this sum
has got the always output 0 or 1 it's
got to always now magically cancel
however and be 0 or be 1 on every 2 the
N input ok so we call this a sum of C
circuit and so first notice if this C
spans the vector space of all functions
from zero one of the end of the reals
then there's always some circuit you can
get you know just by sort of if you
think of these as vectors of link to the
N if it spans the vector space you can
always find some linear combination that
works they represent any particular
vector so you can always get to most to
the N size and the question is do we get
polynomial representations for which
functions can we prove pollen
representations and which ones can we
prove they're no
okay so just some simple examples of C
is a class of to the N and functions and
variables then this is just zero one
polynomials over the reals so the sum of
and is just zero one panel's over the
reals okay with art so each monomial is
just an ant if C is a class of two the
impaired D functions on a variable so
I'm just taking like subsets of inputs
and taking their purity then just this
becomes minus one minus one one
polynomials over the reals okay so it's
just be the the domain of we analysis of
boolean functions okay these are very
well understood namely because both of
these things form a basis for the vector
space of such functions it is exactly to
the N of them and they they are
independent so in this case there are
linear representation of F is unique
because always just one representation
so the shortest is also the longest not
a very interesting question so the more
interesting cases are where the
representations are not unique so you
have some over a complete type
representation like more than two to the
N functions and and then you can start
asking these kinds of questions so the
reason you studied three simple classes
so one is linear threshold functions one
is rectified linear units and one is say
polynomials over the field of P elements
of degree D and this is interesting once
even when D is 2 so quadratic
polynomials and even when P is 2 over f2
all right so for all three classes there
are many more than to the end functions
on in variables so the representations
are not unique and for all three classes
these representations have been studied
so the sum of LTF is a special case of
depth to threshold circuits some of Ray
Lu is depth to neural nets with so
called Rayleigh activations and this
some of say degree 2 polynomials over F
2 this is the domain of higher-order
fuyi analysis so trying to understand
which boolean functions have sparse
representations when I try to write them
as a linear combination of say quadratic
polynomials
so so this is just a recollection of LTF
but I I also wrote it there so it's a
major open problem to find nice
functions without say into the K gate LT
f of LT f circuits for all K so
thresholds of thresholds so you have
thresholds feeding into thresholds so
it's known that they're exponential
lower bounds when you have small weights
so when these when these thresholds
these alphas are they like small
integers between say minus polynomial
and in polynomial so those are very well
known and already in 1994's asked well
what about sums of linear thresholds so
now I have arbitrary weights at the
output and arbitrary weights at the next
layer but I'm requiring you that the
your linear form at the output must
always evaluate to 0 of 1 so it's a very
special case of depth to linear
threshold circuits but still as far as I
know there's no in 21.5 gate lower
bounds that were known I mean in the 1.5
gate lower bounds are known for
threshold of threshold by some work of
Daniel Caine in myself so what we prove
is that for all K there are functions in
mp depending on that K without any of
the case sized sums of linear thresholds
ok so I can always find some function
that doesn't have into the billion sized
sums of up there so it requires into the
billion separate linear thresholds you
know even in a real valued linear
combination to compute the function and
this lifts to so slightly
superpolynomial lower bound state
there's a major open problem which i've
discussed earlier to prove that there's
a function in NP without in the case is
unrestricted circuits so this is like a
very very special case where we can we
can prove such statements
so some of reh loose is basically a
slight nonlinear gate so you you have
these weights it's just like a the
linear form of the threshold thing sorry
this this thing is cutting out but so
like imagine like sometimes this thing
could be negative and what you're
outputting is the maximum of zero and
this thing so it sort of cuts off at
zero but can be linear after that it's a
it's a kind of like somewhat nonlinear
gate that's that's very useful so this
thing does generalize some of LTF so
given any similar LTF you can write it
as a sum over very low efficiently this
very widely studied there are thousands
of references on it and several recent
references give lower bounds for sort of
weird functions which very sharply but
in terms of discrete valued functions I
mean even the parody function has small
sums of Ray loose so like extremely
sensitive functions in a discrete domain
it doesn't seem possible to prove lower
bounds just on things like this so we
generalize we can generalize the sum of
LTF limits to sums of Ray loose just
just as I was a saying before finally
this sum of degree D polynomials thing
so it's a linear combination of these
functions which they could output values
between 0 and P minus 1 ok and then
you're taking a real value linear
combination of them there's some degree
D pollen else you could think of them as
degree 2 yeah this case is already very
interesting so one compelling conjecture
which was raised at a previous Simon
seminar is whether the and function on n
inputs requires super polynomial size
linear combinations of degree two finals
over f2 so I mean it's known that right
if I just said palm you know like linear
polynomials and I'm in the Fourier
domain and the representation is
obviously exponential okay so that's
well known and you can get an upper
bound you can get two to the N over two
sides by just kind of mimicking what
happens in the upper bound for to the
end here when you have degree 2
mewls but there were no non-trivial
lower bounds that I'd know up for like
sums of say even DB two-pound rolls over
FP for any prime P and we proved MP
lower balanced just as is this in the
before so fixed polymer lower bounds in
this case as well
so the key theorem behind all this is a
new instance of health circuit and
alphas albums implies circuit lower
bounds so here's the theorem I'll
explain it carefully so let's see be a
class of functions from 0 1 to the N to
the reals essentially like all we need
is that it's easy to evaluate a given
function f on a boolean assignment like
it's somehow efficient to evaluate that
thing so you can't like really weird
functions so we so assume there's an
epsilon and some algorithm a so they're
given four functions from this class we
can compute the following some product
so we sum over all zr1 assignments and
take the product of all four functions
suppose we can compute this some product
and say 1.99 to the end time so so
something faster than CD in time then we
can show these lower bounds that there
are functions in NP without in the case
i sums of that class of functions and
the super polynomial lower bound so
what's going on here at a high level is
that solving a generalization of sharp
set for this class see so you know if
these were boolean valued things and
it's really just an end of four objects
in this class so solving a
generalization of a sharp set thing
you're counting satisfying assignments
actually lifts to strong lower bounds
for this real valued linear combination
of things in this class so this is like
where I have a circuit analysis
algorithm for some say wheat Class C
like C thresholds and I lift it to a
lower bound for a class where I don't
really know the lower bounds like these
sums of thresholds
so this applies this new easy witness
lemma and several other kind of nice
manipulations unfortunately I mean talk
about it offline but what we do is we
show how to compute these some products
efficiently for LTFS Rey lose and low
degree polynomials
I still have a little bit of time with
so so let me show you how to get this
sum product algorithm for LTF so just to
recall the kind of thing we want to
compute right over here is the sum over
all doing assignments of the product or
LTS okay
so we're going to use the old fact that
counting subset-sum solutions can be
done in faster than to the end time for
in items so you have in numbers and you
want to count the subset some solutions
that say you have some fixed target you
want to know the number of subsets that
sum to the target you can do this faster
than a numerating all to the end so so
the proof is so given these weights so
like these are the items sorry W 1
through W a and the target T we want to
know the number of subsets that sums to
this target T ok so here's the algorithm
it's some very sort of standard sorting
and searching type thing you break the
items into two sets so W 1 through W n
over 2 and W and over 2 plus 1 2 WN you
numerate all possible subsets of say the
first half you make a list of all those
subset sums and you sort all the sums in
that list ok whatever increasing order
say then you enumerate all possible
subsets of the other half and for every
subset you get that sums to a value V u
binary search for a value of V Prime in
the other list so that these two sum to
the target right so this is a this will
be one subset some solution so that's
how you would find a subset sum solution
it computes the total number of subsets
something to this thing you say for
every some value V that appears in your
first list you store the number in V of
subsets which have value V prime and
then if you find a value V prime in your
binary search you just add that number
of subsets is some running sum so the
point is that this is just doing sorting
and searching no big deal ok
and the it's a sub counting subset sum
algorithm and it takes to the N over 2
times poly in time through the binary
searches polygons in total
okay
all right so how do we get this sum
product algorithm for LTF from that so
again the claim is if I give you four
linear threshold functions we want to
compute the sum over the product of four
of them in this kind of time so it just
requires a little algebraic manipulation
to get it done yes yeah yeah so it so
it's important it's a it's important
that yeah this is easier among the the
slides that wasn't able to occur it's
important that in each of these three
representations it suffices to have to
have like bit precision poly in right
because I said they were arbitrary reals
but if I'm going to get a lower bound
against NP and I'm gonna guess yeah I'm
gonna guess a circuit like in my mp
thing yeah it's very important that the
precision is like can be made like say
poly and without loss of generality so
it turns out that for these these three
representations that's true no so it's
just like sorting and searching so I
mean if they have poly in precision and
it's just poly an overhead yeah yeah
yeah it's an important important point
right so so we're essentially solving
this sharp set thing for like and a for
LPS okay all right so so here's the
proof it will just fit there okay so so
first we start with something called an
exact LTF this is just like a LTF except
the only output 1 when the linear form
is exactly your target instead of being
at least your target you want it to be
exactly your target okay then you output
1 if it's just greater smaller you up at
0 all right so the first observation is
that if we can count subsets some
solutions in a certain amount of time
then we can also count like some overall
AG of a for an exact LTF in the same
time because this is really this is
really asking whether X is a subset sum
so whether this subset is a solution or
not so it's just immediate that like
it's counting such that some solutions
let's use some solutions to these exact
LTS ok all right so then we use a very
nice result of Hanson and Podolski from
2010 that says every LTI on n inputs can
be written as a polynomial size linear
combination of exact LTS it's not at all
obvious when you have like really large
weights so using this we can write so
this is the sum we want to compute the
sum over all to the end of this product
of 4 we can write well each of these LPS
can be written as a sum of e opf is
exact LTS okay for some exactly LTS then
applying the distributive law you're
just like you know commute the product
and sum to get sum of products ok we now
we're now we're having some sum over
Pollyanna products of for exact LTS ok
and previous sum once more now we've
reduced apollyon calls to counting a
number of solutions to a product of 4
LTS so just just rearrange the order of
summation all right now the final effect
is that if you have a end of say even so
let's say and a 4
LTS a LPs they can be represented by
another LTI by just modifying the
weights so if changing the weights
around in fact an an of any polynomial
number of elts can be written as one LTF
all right so basically we reduce this to
poly encaustic counting subsets some
solutions because this is an alt F and
so we can compute this much faster than
to the end time so that's how the
algorithm goes which I don't have time
to tell you about how the how that
algorithm implies the lower bound I have
slides linked over out there all right
so now I want to share a question yeah
just how many things are yeah yeah you
could do that as well you could do that
as well I don't know if it saves you
very much it's just an extra poly n
factor I don't know if it saves you much
but you could yeah you could just count
the number that make this at least T so
in fact the the Ray Lou algorithm is a
vast generalization of the counting
subset something because you actually
want to multiply by some linear form if
it's at least zero or something yeah
yeah so the the [ __ ] thing is like
some generalization of the counting
stuffs that something so which is even
more complicated
so so I want to conclude with some open
problems so there are many so we know
that for each K there is some function
let's say an end time into the order K
the for without these in the case sized
sums of LTS alright so why can't we just
show that like NP isn't in poli-sci sums
of LT ups so maybe like show that set
requires in the case size some of the
LTS for all K I don't know why not this
this representation should not be very
powerful
mainly because you're requiring that
every single sum that you do is going to
output a zero one value it seems like a
very stringent requirement so another
thing that I raised earlier show that
quasi and P doesn't have threshold
threshold circuits of sub-quadratic size
so these result some probabilistic
polynomials that could imply such a
thing so here's like maybe the you know
it's like low ambition thing but why not
so there's a function and show there's a
function in time to the order n within
MP Oracle with help say six inside
circuits we recall it was like five in
for like NP and this is still an open
problem so like you know what is the you
know why can't we at least push this a
little bit and or maybe there is some
reason why maybe we can figure out like
why it's hard to prove that me probably
not but yeah I just want us to think
about these questions so just even have
these like embarrassing frontiers so
here's something that is really weird
and I don't know what to do with it
so that sharp set problem I was talking
about so it the you get two to the N
over two time algorithms right that's
like still exponential but if you've got
degree two polynomials over F two I know
how to solve this sharp set problem for
such a representation in polynomial time
it can be solved in polynomial time
so therefore this class real valued and
your combinations of these quadratic
panels they shouldn't even represent CNF
if it did then like the whole at least
the counting hierarchy would collapse
the NP or something like this
so so why can't we prove that so if you
have a polynomial time sharp set
algorithm for something that should just
you know completely like this shouldn't
I really stronger about so finally we
know that like you say if Sat is in poly
time we get some lower bounds where we
get to remove the non determinism so
deterministic time in the log n is not
in P poly if Sat was there in quasi poly
time and quasi-polynomial time is not in
P poly so the question is is such a
connection true for gap circuit set so
if I put gap circuits at in P can I get
the termina stick around instead of
non-interest 'ok once so right I was
getting non-deterministic lower we're
about scan I get something else
deterministic okay so it's known that
right the converse of this is true in a
sense or like the famous theorem of
implies one big reason is that if time
order to the end doesn't have say two to
the N over 100 sites there's some fixed
exponential size then you do get gap
circuits algorithms in poly time so the
it's sort of asking is there a converse
of any kind but with deterministic
classes another problem I think we can
think about okay thank you
yes sir if I simply does not have a
sensual threshold so so easy should so
we know those things for you to be empty
so just that that your new easy witness
is not sharp enough to prove that so if
you are there like a super-tight is it
witnessing you go get that yeah yeah if
you had some so I think you should be
able to prove maybe quasi P to the N P
like a lower bound for that kind of
thing maybe I mean it depends on how
things work but yeah the point is that
the the new one is not tight enough to
get that kind of
so
Thank You bleep Leslie in export that's
a good question so like what hypotheses
was sort of the minimum hypothesis that
would imply P space not in P poly I'm
not really sure I don't really know yeah
another interesting question on this
line is like what interesting hypothesis
would imply NP not in P poly because I'm
only getting fixed poly SCI so we're
balancing me yeah this is a really
interesting question and because those
who are bound should be true to but so
what is the algorithm that implies them
I don't know like I also got five great
sense educate you about like anything so
is there like you did that that's as
sharp as it could go or the other
cancers where you can be improved like
for instance you will you always use PC
P pair of pliers right you could choose
a different verifier yeah so yeah this
is a space where not many people have
thought about I think so like if you use
like some other kind of verifier that
would translate to a different kind of
circuit analysis problem directly you
saw so so maybe certain verifiers
are more amenable to like getting this
kind of algorithmic connection yeah it's
a very very fascinating question like I
think like it one time someone asked me
well well suppose you could computer
like as a Nash equilibrium faster than
exhaustive search like what would this
imply and well I don't know what the
verifier would look like so I don't yeah
yeah this is
well is there a Columbus to the back
like this is like can you use this to
derive PCPs for example oh I don't know
I don't know about that yeah I mean this
sort of uses the machinery and in some
way to say that this analysis algorithm
is enough I mean the way you can think
about it as I make the verifier sort of
stronger and more power like the point
is like the weak the requirements on
like verification are weaker and weaker
and weaker then the analysis algorithm I
have to get doesn't have to do so much
that's sort of how I use it I don't know
of any kind of converse